people that I I isolated that sit in
their house and just count their money
and big build big houses and count how
big their boat is I'm not sure they're
that happy the most tortured Souls I
know are extremely wealthy people the
happiest people I know are often people
who have no money now uh that doesn't
mean you don't want to have any money
but you have to make sure you understand
what money is all about it's designed to
make you I think uh have a better life
but you're gonna have a better life if
you help other people now I tell people
all the time when I'm making
philanthropic or pitches when you when
you're trying to give away
um when you give away money to give away
time help other people you'll feel
happier about yourself happier people
live longer grumpy people don't live as
long also there's a special place in
heaven reserved for people that do this
now people laugh when I say that but I
say why would you want to take a chance
and I'm wrong I could be right